so we're taping this at about 2:00 p.m.
Eastern today and about 9:00 p.m.
Eastern tonight President Obama is going
to give a big speech which a lot of what
he's going to talk about is already
being leaked and it sounds like we are
going to go to war in Iraq in Syria with
ISIL is Isis whatever you want to call
it are we gonna have congressional
approval if he's saying he doesn't need
it now again the speech is tonight so
we'll see if anything changes today this
all seems extremely disappointing to me
because I believe that Congress is
supposed to declare war and the
president supposed to execute it not the
other way around but President Obama is
already claiming that that's not the
case which is exactly what he did a year
ago in Syria when he wanted to have air
strikes that we didn't have and by the
way he already went ahead and did this
once in Libya a couple years ago
remember we had that Xbox Kinect
military action or whatever they called
it okay so I have Jake and Steve who
know more about politics than I do so
I'm I'm just so disappointed in this
already and I know we're jumping the gun
a little bit but that's why I wanted you
because I wanted to get us on the record
before everybody you can already see it
in the media everybody is ready to go to
war Jake you're jumping at your seat
already so Chris Matthews is at it again
just today he was talking about how you
know we're gonna have to take out we're
gonna have to get our hands dirty and
fighting Isis and this and later he'll
claim that he didn't want to go into
Iraq and Syria precisely what he did
during the Iraq war
yeah identical he said the bush should
go out on Mount Rushmore for what he did
in Iraq and then later said oh no I was
against the Iraq war the whole time
right yeah so now look we were the first
show in covering how horrific Isis is
they're the exact people that I is
diametrically opposed to everything we
believe it right as progressives you
can't find a more polar opposite for
progressives than Isis right so the
foreheads
yes we're Pro ads there
you've got to get congressional
authorization yes so let's back up so
dab it yes and lay the legal framework
for how this is supposed to work yeah
let me throw the quotes in real quick
and then you can take away the legal
stuff so first let's start with what
President Obama told Chuck Todd on Meet
the Press on Sunday here we go
he said he's confident that I have the
authorization that I need to protect the
American people okay that's extremely
vague but that's what he was saying the
first time now let's just look at a
quote that he said in 2007 this is when
he was a senator before he was president
didn't really believe the same thing the
president does not have the power under
the Constitution to unilaterally
authorize a military attack in a
situation that does not involve stopping
an actual or imminent threat to the
nation and as Obama made clear on his
Sunday appearance on Meet the Press this
is not the case in Iraq or Syria that's
President Obama to Charlie Savage he
said I want everybody to understand that
we have not seen an immediate
intelligence about threats to the
homeland from ISIL that's not what this
is about okay so now Steve you can clean
that up for us right so if the country
is under go to war Congress has to
declare war now in limited military
action against an imminent threat the
present can act unilaterally with that
getting pre-approval from Congress but
here there is no imminent threat to the
United States from Isis as Obama said
right they said and this is the exact
way you need to get congressional
authority to go to war now the saddest
part of all of this is that our
president is completely backtracking
from the position that he had as as a
candidate for presidency we spoke very
eloquently about the restraint of power
on the presidency and and the need to to
go through the proper channels and now
he's basically completely adopted John
use ridiculous unitary executive policy
and john-john U is crowing all around
saying you up this is the bush policy
and that's the Obama policy okay so
sickening and pathetic so real quick
John you he was a former legal counsel
in the Bush administration and let's
look at his quote on this this is what
he said when he was in the Bush
administration when they were trying to
legitimize everything they were doing
the President may deploy military force
preemptively against terrorist
organizations or states that Harbor or
support them whether or not they can be
linked to a specific terrorist attack of
September 11 this is basically the
justification that Obama is going to use
tonight
so John use in essence Dick Cheney's
lawyer right along with David Addington
and I thought that he should be banned
from being a law professor anywhere in
the country of how hideous and
ridiculous his torture memos were her
Priya's preemptive strike unitary
executive authority memos etc now the
guy we elected for change has adopted
all of Cheney's lawyers tactics so let's
establish a couple of things first of
all President Obama is a liar okay
that's he lied about change was a
fundamental lie of his campaign change
change change when he apparently never
indeed intended to bring us change okay
he intended to do it slight little
changes around the corner right pocket
change Yeah right so now the second
thing is it's not just bad policy it's
also bad politics now who's pushing
President Obama into this action
everybody write a TV the Republicans
certainly John McCain's of the world
also a lot of Democrats coming out
saying we have to be tougher all right
great then you authorize right so then
that's that that's the part I don't get
about this if I agree with you the media
clearly has no problem going to war the
Republicans are all about it right now
and even some of the Democrats are now
into it so why is he either afraid or
reluctant to go to Congress here
III don't know but I want to go back to
the legal authority on this because it
drives me freaking crazy
so John you is you know heralded as some
sort of genius some legal Jesus for for
coming up with these theories but it's
not it's just by Fiat he's just making
stuff up so he says with with torture
he's like okay torture is not allowed so
you know what let's just call it
enhanced arrogation then it's okay so
it's not any kind of clever and legal
theory it's just it's just utter
[ __ ] okay when it comes to Fourth
Amendment he just he's been in a
footnote to a memo the fourth limit does
not apply to domestic military action on
what basis on
legal precedent he just made this up and
then take Cheney and everyone turns on
says see our lawyers that is okay so he
said you know that is the mind-boggling
tautology that drives me crazy because
you hire lawyers these uh these
charlatans to say exactly what you
wanted to say then you turn and say see
is justify for me to do what I want to
do want what I want to do all along and
the worst part of all Dave and Jack is
for me is that this is coming from
President Obama a former constitutional
law professor okay
George Bush is not a smart guy we all
get that okay he went to school based on
his connections he [ __ ] around and got
high all the time but but Obama worked
hard okay and he's a smart guy thing
Aquaman he it really really just breaks
my heart breaks a faith in the system in
so many ways that that Obama is going to
butcher out using Bush's guys to do
exactly what Bush did and it's it's read
a so so why isn't he going to Congress
if we look to me look I'm not a military
planner as I say all the time so I don't
know what we should do there however I
do believe we should abide by the laws
of this country so if he said I'm gonna
lay out the case and now I'm gonna go to
Congress and then Congress authorized
that I would say at least the process
worked it's really stunning how bad he
is at politics when it doesn't come to
his own specific election like in his
elections he was strong and ami he
mutilated MIT Romney ran great ads
etcetera right but when he gets to
policy issues he's like oh and he's
tripping over himself look if they're
pushing you to war you all right let me
try to bring down the superlatives here
but look why wouldn't you get them on
the hook politically by saying hey you
guys authorized this war you wanted to
do this war now if it goes south on them
they're gonna say one it was your idea
to go to war it's your fault
number two we didn't authorize it and so
we were against it and number three you
abused your authority to do it and it's
an impeachable offense so that's what I
have written right here doesn't it give
him cover so that's so but we don't
think he's an idiot so then
the what's actually happened thank you
think these advisers are idiots I really
but I wasn't so all right put on
immigration they're incredibly stupid I
did a story on eight on the actors last
night on this they're being incredibly
stupid announcer but really the real
reason he's doing it and it doesn't mean
it's not meaning that just because
they're stupid doesn't mean there's no
reason it's just I think they're
calculating it wrong so their
calculation here is well if we go to ask
for permission from Congress it'll look
weak and we and everybody's telling us
we look weak Chuck Todd was on TV
today's comparing me to Jimmy Carter we
got a little strong a strong president
don't ask for permission they just break
the law and invade Oh several countries
at the same time yeah that's so stupid
but that's what they mistake strength
for yeah
when astral strength is the courage of
your convictions and saying this is what
I'm doing this is how I'm doing it and
if you don't like it I'm gonna kick your
ass I think there might be something
else too I think maybe he thinks that if
he goes to Congress and doesn't get
authority because the Republicans dick
him over and then he can't go and do
anything and then they'll say why don't
you do anything why didn't you do
anything he's a little bit screw in that
regard so that's what happened last time
right because everyone cuz then the
world wasn't behind him and it seemed
like he was gonna have to do it alone
this time it seems very obvious to me
that he would get whatever he wants out
of Congress in some ways I guess now
that we've had this conversation I'm
glad that he's not asking for
authorization cuz he would get it and
then all future presidents could use
that authorization to invade any country
they like in the Middle East
indefinitely because it's not even a
specific country at this point we're
talking about Isis that's in Iraq Syria
and a little bit in Lebanon and God
knows where else they're going to yeah
so thank God he's not asking for the
authorization because it would be abused
yeah but but you're right you it would
seem in Washington like a political
defeat if he didn't get authorization
but in my world I'd be like look this is
a mess and if Congress doesn't authorize
it then I turn around go these sons of
[ __ ] made a mess it's their fault I
mean forget nobody you're a smart guy
savvy you're playing three-dimensional
chess he's playing he's playing checkers
maybe he's playing a Kinect for I don't
know but not gonna be quite good
actually you're right
but he he doesn't want I think he wants
to go okay he want he thinks he has to
get going and he's afraid of risking a
political loss at this moment not not
realizing that a loss today is actually
a giant win later because it's
definitely gonna go south it's not gonna
go well whoo this limit is gonna go well
I mean pretty sure our military
exploration in the Middle East usually
goes well okay why why I want
congressional authority for any such
action is because I want people on the
hook I want names
I want people sitting on the Senate
floor on the Congress's floor and saying
I vote in favor of this action and I'm
representing my constituents and then
when that happens I want people to see
it when dead bodies come back from from
from fighting our soldiers are dead on
them to see it they're having an
informed decision not this [ __ ] rush
to war you know to the drumbeats of the
media and all the war profiteers are
saying yes yes yes and they've got a lot
of money and then we turn it to the to
some you know Kardashians or whatever it
may be and we came and show caskets of
our of our service people coming back
from from the war yeah all right words
characterize Obama in conclusion afraid
afraid afraid always acting out of fear
worrying about what Washington
conventional wisdom is gonna say about
him it's just an incredibly
short-sighted strategy I mean this is a
perfect example I mean no one really
knows what the right answer is with Isis
okay cuz I mean we also hate Assad but
you know Isis also hates Assad
strengthen him at to them yeah and you
know so we don't really know what we
should do and normally has the answers
this is a perfect time to go to Congress
come over the consensus and come up with
a plan and then if that plan fails it
fails okay but at least you have a plan
going forward and you're not rushing
into it so okay so then final thought on
this because we do have to wrap up so -
you're afraid point is this this Timmy
strikes me as what will be the biggest
failure of him forgetting all the all
the hope and change it didn't happen all
that this idea that he was the guy that
could have sat us all down he could
still do it tonight I hope it I hope
everything we said here is wrong but it
seems to me that he's still the guy that
could sit us all down and say look this
thing is happening I'm gonna go through
the proper channels this is why we have
to do it I know we've [ __ ] up the
Middle East but we still will have
responsibilities and and all that and
but he won't do that and that that's the
part that saddens me more than anything
else here so bring us our burrito for me
the saddest part is that all the
law-breaking and all the all the bad
things that that the Bush administration
did during their eight years that reign
of terror this progressive president
so-called progressive president has
embraced all of it and has normalized it
and going forward that's the new order
and that is the worst part of it all
Michael Moore just said President Obama
and unfortunately will be known only for
being the first black president he's
done nothing else accomplished nothing
else and today you're right Dave he has
the opportunity to change the game to
give a different kind of speech one word
he explains why we have to follow the
Constitution why we elected him in the
first place right but he will not give
that speech he will give a speech
tailor-made to the Washington insiders
who will then say he's tough for a day
and a half and then immediately change
their minds and pillory him for all the
decisions that they forced him into and
he's never gonna catch up he's always
gonna play from behind he believes his
presidency is already over all he's
gonna do is float in the wind with
conventional wisdom until he leaves
office and it is really really sad all
right well I rarely end the video saying
that I hope that we're wrong on this one
but I hope that we're wrong and watching
a couple hours and I guess we'll find
out